hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation now begin
with a couple of quick announcements a
number of you have asked if I would do
these sessions live and here's the thing
I'd love to do these live I love that
engagement directly on the fly the
challenge is that when we've done test
there's a sort of lag and a synchrony
between you know the movement of the
lips and the words that I'm actually
saying so it kind of looks like you're
watching some kind of foreign film
that's being dubbed so it's kind of less
than satisfying so I don't know let us
know whether that would bother you or
not and I'm happy to try a live session
if we want to give that a roll also a
number of you asked if I would do some
Q&A sessions I am happy to do that so
send in your questions many of you put
questions in the comments and we'll see
maybe I'll do the Q&A live or maybe I'll
extract you know some of the more
fruitful questions that are listed in
the comments or that you send to me
directly and I can address those and
perhaps a series of sessions that will
be interlaced with the daily equation
episodes that we have been creating okay
good so today let me do something a
little bit different you know you no
doubt have noticed that I've grouped the
early equations they're all having to do
with Einstein's special theory of
relativity motivated by our first
equation equals mc-squared how could you
not begin a series called your daily
equation without starting with e equals
mc-squared
and there are a handful of other
equations in special relativity that I'm
looking forward to discussing with you
but just to mix it up a little bit today
I'm going to do a different equation a
kind of simple equation that I don't
know sort of surprisingly mine
slapping in a way it's a little bit
maybe it's even surprising that it's
surprising but it is one of those
equations you know I just tried it out
on my on my son he thought it was kind
of cool it's an old one many of you no
doubt have seen this but let's just take
a quick look and see this little
analysis for today's daily equations so
what is the equation that I have in mind
let me bring up the iPad good so the the
equation is dead simple it's simply this
right it's one equals point nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine and it just
keeps on going with the nines and the
claim is that this is a true equation
that we have here and it is it is
surprising right I mean when you when
you just look at that many people would
say hey you know the thing that you have
there on the right hand side yeah may go
on forever but the right hand side is
clearly always gonna be less than when
it gets close to one ever closer to one
but it never quite reaches one but the
claim is that if you take those sort of
three dots at the end seriously there
and imagine this thing does go on
forever then that really is an equality
it really does equal one now there are a
number of ways of establishing this
depending on the level of mathematical
rigor that you'd like to use my goal
here is just to kind of give you a sense
of how to show that it's true and I'll
leave it for the mathematicians among
you to fill in all of the subtleties but
you know so I'll say two things about
this one is you can approach this
question by just writing down some
finite versions of the infinite decimal
expansion and seeing how they differ
from one so the difference of 0.9 from
one of course is just 1/10 if you were
to go to point 99 then the difference
from one of course would be 1/100 and of
course you see the pattern if you go to
the enth decimal place 2 you point 9
a finite number but any of these guys
then you'll differ from one by one over
ten to the nth power and you know that's
just formalizing what you already know
by looking at the expression even
naively that the more nines you have the
closer you get to one and you can
formalize that a little bit you could
say hey you know if X is equal to 0.99
nine and go on forever with that if X
itself were less than one so if X were
less than one then you said yourself
well there's some difference between 1
and X let's call that difference Epsilon
clue it's gonna be pretty small if there
is an X that is not equal to 1 and you
then recognize from what we have above
that by choosing n sufficiently large
you can make the difference between 1
and the finite expression to be
arbitrarily small 1 over 10 to the N
gets smaller and smaller and gets bigger
and bigger so whatever epsilon there is
if it's a finite nonzero value then you
run into a contradiction because he just
choose n large enough so that n large
enough will insure us that 1 minus X
webserver that 1 minus X this guy over
here will actually be less than Epsilon
because 1 minus X is just 1 over 10 to
the N and make n large you know if you
can make 1 over 10 TN smaller than any
finite value of Epsilon so that pretty
much establishes right there that X has
to be equal to 1 there is no finite
nonzero value of epsilon which would be
the difference between 1 and X good ok
that's sort of one way of establishing
it but that doesn't I don't know that
just sort of formalizes this idea that
0.9999 9 gets closer and closer to 1 it
might still leave you feeling
dissatisfied and when I gave that little
argument to my son just a little few min
ago he was a little dissatisfied with it
but he was satisfied with the following
argument which it's kind of a nice way
of thinking about it so let's play this
game so let's let X equal point nine
nine nine and imagine this thing just
keeps on going forever
well let's now multiply both sides by
ten so we got ten x equals y all note
multiplied by ten you just move the
decimal over by one so you get nine
point nine nine and this thing just
keeps on going forever good that's nice
because now let's do ten X minus X and
on the left hand side of course 10 X
minus X is 9 times X and on the right
hand side well the point 9 9 9 subtract
that out from nine point nine nine not
it just kills everything after the
decimal point so we get nine x equals 9
and then lo and behold right there we
have x equals one and that's kind of I
don't know for many people that's
psychologically maybe a little bit more
convincing or satisfying than the
previous argument and there you have it
so you do have this equality that is
today's equation that is one point nine
nine nine
you just keep on going now as I was
saying there's a way in which this is
both surprising because you kind of
stare at it and you think that it can't
quite really be true but we just showed
that it is but there's another way of
thinking about it where it's more
surprising that it is surprising and
what I mean by that is nobody would
blink an eye if I wrote down 1/3 equals
0.33 3 e 3 and so forth let those guys
go on forever that one is almost second
nature to most of us but now if I
multiply both sides by 3 well 3 times
1/3 is 1 and 3 times 0.33 3 1 so on is
is 0.9999
and so on so from that perspective the
surprising equation at the top over here
is nothing but this boring equation over
here that nobody would take second
notice of x 3 now you think that a
boring equation this one over here would
stay boring if you just multiply both
sides by 3 in fact you might say well if
it's boring then 3 times it is going to
be 3 times as boring right but yeah kind
of surprisingly you multiply it by 3 and
you get an equation the one that we
started with
which is for most people at least at
first glance kind of surprising so this
is just one of those interesting
mathematical niceties mathematical facts
that you can try out on your on your
friends and your family probably at the
moment more on your family then your
friends although you can do it digitally
of course and it is a kind of unexpected
equality between two mathematical terms
each of which is straightforward in its
own right and it's just unexpectedly
that they are equal to each other but as
we just saw very easy to establish at
least at the level of convincing nough
sand rigor of convincing this as
word that we're doing here okay so
that's just a little bite-sized version
of your daily equation and we'll take it
up again tomorrow with another equation
again as I do these I kind of figure out
what I'm gonna do on the fly so I'm not
precisely sure what I'm going to do but
again send in your suggestions keeping
track of those I'm in fact this one I
should say really did come from a
suggestion from one of you guys so I
appreciate forget who it was
but you know I was familiar with the
this curiosity and but someone brought
it up as something that would be worth a
moment of explanation so thank you very
much and also if you um if you want to
do some live Q&A just send in your
questions and I'm happy to go through
them and either answer them in one of
these sessions or in a live Q&A itself
okay that's all for today that is your
daily equation look forward to seeing
you next time until then take care